- What's up Believe Nation?
I started the Mentor
Me Series with the goal
to try to learn from people
who've done a lot more than us,
hang around them a little bit longer,
and by being in their environment,
hopefully some of their
mindsets, their beliefs,
their way of thinking, seep into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today, we're going to
learn from Kevin O'Leary
and his investing rules.
Mentor Me Kevin.
And as always guys, as
you're watching the clip,
if you hear something that
really really resonates
with you, please leave it
down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired, and also
when you write it down,
you're much more likely to
lock it in for yourself too.
Enjoy!
(inspirational music)
- Diversification is the
only free lunch in investing,
and I see this happen so many times.
Here's my basic lesson that I've learned
that I never vary from.
And this works.
Trust me, it works.
Never more than five
percent of your portfolio
in any one name, no matter
how great the story is.
If it's the next Nortel, if
it's the next Rim, who cares.
Five percent max waiting.
For me, usually it's
two-and-a-half to three percent.
I never let a stock get bigger
than that in my portfolio.
I sell into the strength all the time.
Secondly, never, ever, ever
more than 20% in any one sector.
So if you love gold, you
just can't get past 20%
of your net worth in gold, or
energy, or any other sector,
or financial services,
so good sectoral
diversification is crucial.
And finally, for me, I'm over 60% weighted
in debt now versus equity.
Not government debt, not treasury bonds,
but corporate debt.
Remember that a double-B or triple-B bond
is serviced before they pay
the dividend on a common stock,
so I like to own right
up the balance sheet,
so I own a lot of prefs,
converts, senior debt,
floating rate notes, I love that stuff.
Because when they get upgraded,
I get capital appreciation.
Meanwhile, I get a check.
The key to life is the check coming in.
It's the cash.
If you always, always, always
look at the free cash flow,
this will keep you safe,
because the only friend
you're going to have when
you're old and crusty
is not your dog, not your
kids, it's the cash in the bank
that's still going to love you.
- In your book, you also
say when you're investing,
you should have an
element of fear in there.
- You should make the assumption when you
make an investment, there's
some probability you'll lose it.
It'll go to zero.
And that's why you need to
have, you know, a reserve,
like a backup plan, some cash set aside,
that if everything blows up, you're okay.
I find it extraordinary when people
make their first liquidity event,
and they have some capital,
that they blow it all again.
That is the biggest mistake.
You've got to take a nut,
even if it stays in cash,
or it's a very very liquid safe security,
to say that I don't touch.
It goes back to what my mother taught me.
Spend the interest, never the principal.
I mean look, you know, I make
a lot of crazy investments.
I don't touch the principal.
I learned something a long
time ago from my mother.
You're going to find this fascinating.
When I was a seven-year-old boy,
and she was working at that time,
she used to take me to the
bank with her every Thursday.
That's when they paid the
girls where she worked.
And she'd take a third of her paycheck
and put it into bonds and
dividend-paying stocks.
She used to say to my brother and I then,
boys, never spend the
principal, only the interest.
I had no idea what she was talking about,
but she was drilling that
into my head for a reason,
I think, became very
important decades later.
After she passed away, I became
the executor for her estate.
For the first time, I saw a secret account
she kept from both of her
husbands her whole life,
made up of dividend-paying
large cap stocks
and corporate credit.
Do you have any idea of the
performance of that portfolio?
She blew away every indices.
I was amazed.
She wasn't a portfolio manager.
She was just a concerned mother
that needed to have capital
no matter what happened.
I started to do some research.
You may find this fascinating.
Over the last 40 years, over
70% of the market's returns
have come from dividends,
not capital appreciation.
She must have intuitively
felt that and knew that.
That forever changed my
investment philosophy.
I'm a dividend guy.
I only buy stocks that pay dividends.
I'll never buy a stock that
doesn't return capital,
because the data tells you not to.
Unless you're a masterful stock picker,
and you know exactly when to buy and sell,
you can't, in my view, beat those odds.
40 years, 71% returns.
That's it for me, dividends only.
I like gold because in
a way it's a stabilizer.
It's an insurance policy.
I listen to all the gold pundits,
and they're always wrong
as far as I'm concerned.
It's impossible to time the moves.
I've owned gold for decades,
and I simply have a five percent waiting.
I look at it quarterly.
When it becomes more than five percent,
I sell into the strength,
and when it weakens, I
buy into the weakness.
It's just a stabilizer.
I'm not one of those guys
that's going to go to 40% waiting in gold.
- Okay.
- I don't believe the
hyperinflation story.
It hasn't happened.
Gold is popular for a
whole host of reasons.
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- And five percent seems to be enough.
It's worked for me in
portfolio management.
It's the only security I own
that doesn't pay a dividend.
- So, Kevin, I guess,
do you not care if gold
goes to 2,000 or 5,000 dollars an ounce?
You're still going to buy gold?
- Yeah, I don't care.
Like let it run.
I'll be selling into that strength,
keeping at five percent waiting.
What I've learned.
I'm an old crusty investor.
When everybody is saying
you got to own it,
you should be selling it,
because when it corrects,
it doesn't touch the
sides on the way down.
So I simply say five
percent's good for me.
Some people like it 10, 15% waiting.
I'm a five percent guy.
And I'm disciplined about it.
I hope it runs to 5,000.
I don't care.
I'll be selling, selling,
selling, selling,
all the way up, keeping
it at five percent,
and when it corrects back down to 2,000,
I'll be buying it in.
It's fun.
That's the way you should work with gold.
Never get so caught up that you take
all your dividend-yielding securities
that are also a hedge against inflation
and put it into a commodity like gold.
What's the value of a stock
that never returns capital
to its shareholders?
I don't know.
Because the only way you can make money
is if somebody else is
willing to buy that position
at a higher price for some
emotional reason perhaps,
or for some foresight
that maybe the company
will return capital one day,
and I think, what you learn as an investor
over multiple decades is
the only thing that matters
is free cash flow.
That's it.
There is no other reason to own a stock.
And with that philosophy, it
brings in you into a place
where you focus on a
company's ability to generate
incremental cash flow, because just owning
a dividend-paying stock
is not good enough,
because let's say we find
a stock today that's paying
a three percent dividend
yield and tomorrow,
because its forecast for
sales get cut in half,
the stock drops by 50%, now
it's yielding six percent.
I don't want to own that stock either,
so my test in this index that I've created
with FTSE Russell looks
at the balance sheet.
Every year we test to make
sure that the company is viable
in its ability to generate cash.
This is extremely conservative investing.
This is for the long haul.
These tools are not for,
as you're suggesting,
for spicy, you know,
the hot stock du jour.
I've done that.
I've been there.
Let the young legs do that.
I have zero interest in that.
I don't care what the hot new stock is.
When a company comes public,
I won't own it either.
It's got to prove to
me over multiple years
that it can continue to generate cash
before it even fits into what I'm doing,
so I'm really boring,
and I like it that way.
- So a great company doesn't necessarily
have to equal a great stock.
They can be two very different
things from your perspective.
- There's many companies
where I buy their products
and services, I would
never touch their stock.
So it's sort of, we're
talking about real money here,
the stuff that you need to preserve.
When I think about my
family trust, I can't afford
to mess around with that.
- What investments are you liking today?
- I'm liking very simple
deals where I can understand
the business model.
I'll give you an example
of how boring and simple
and how successful it can be.
This is from Shark Tank.
I look at a lot of deals on
Shark Tank and on Dragon's Den,
because I invest five
percent of my net worth
every year in venture deals.
So I used to have to find
them; now they come to me.
I've got two platforms to work on.
This is a Shark Tank deal.
So Oprah has a hairdresser.
Interesting guy.
His hobby was tea.
This tea you drink.
And he became what's called a nose.
He had a certain skill to be able to smell
(mumbles) teas and blend them.
One day he gives, a couple of years ago,
a cup of tea to Oprah
while he's doing her hair.
She sips it and says this
is the best tea I ever had.
She goes on the show a half an hour later
and says this tea called Talbott Teas
is the best tea I've ever had.
He gets orders the next day for $500,000.
You know the Oprah effect;
you've heard of it, right?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- He can't finance that.
So he comes on Shark Tank and
he's looking for $250,000.
I agree to buy 35% of
the company for that.
I love tea.
It's so simple.
Gets on Oprah, 500,000
orders, Neiman Marcus,
all kinds of individuals
ordering on the Internet.
Simple.
Tea, orders, cash flow, right?
While we're in the
middle of doing the deal,
the show airs, and Jamba
Juice, a public company,
says we want to be in the tea business,
we love this story, we love the brand,
I want to buy the company.
I haven't even written the check yet.
And bang, the deal's done.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Yes, wow.
That's the kind of deal I like.
Because it was simple.
It's not a complicated tech story.
It's tea.
Tea with a brand.
Now you go into a Jamba Juice
anywhere in North America,
that's my Talbott Teas.
- Wow.
- Isn't that wonderful?
- It is wonderful.
That's why you are...
- That's why I am Mr. Wonderful.
But you know, I look at this way.
The simple deals are the
ones you make money on.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- So I take that cash back.
I redeploy it.
So I like simple stories with
revenue attached to them.
You know the high-tech stuff,
I came out of that market.
It's so complicated and
so much can go wrong,
so I just love deals where they
see an easy path to revenue.
- So thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you learn from this video,
what clip spoke to you
the most, and what are you
going to take from these
clips and immediately apply
to your life or to your business somehow.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout-out
to the Lonely Bookaneer.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word", and for making
that awesome YouTube video
on it as well.
I really, really really
appreciate your support,
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
- [Reviewer] I definitely
think that this book
is about finding the core
thing you want for your work,
your life, and your business.
- So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.